to present the award for Best Original
Screenplay the oscar-winning director
and star of Braveheart Mel Gibson Mel
Gibson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
consider the writer locked away in a
lonely room waiting for lady Muse to a
light gracefully and turned the stark
blank empty void of a page into the
stuff of masterpiece who wrote this
stuff for Best Original Screenplay here
are the nominees Alan Ball for American
Beauty
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like a little kid begging me to play
with it my name's Charlie Kaufland
for being John Malkovich that simulates
for our client self well the experience
of being you actually I've cancer Paul
Thomas Anderson for Magnolia
so my bars I never change Oh M night
Shyamalan for The Sixth Sense
[Applause]
creams Mike Lee for topsy-turvy such
respect for words I have continued and
kept on my music in order that they can
be it's their more than wet setting
I have always subordinated my words to
your music lightning rod the Oscar goes
to Alan Ball for America
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Alan Ball
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much
I wow this is heavy
salmon does I thank my lucky stars for
you every day for your extraordinary
talent your tenacity and your friendship
and for getting it just right dan and
Bruce he made a promise to me to keep me
involved you kept it what were you
thinking an amazing cast in this movie
that a screenwriter can only dream about
Kevin Spacey you do indeed rule Anette
you are astounding West Thor Amina Chris
Alison Peter Sam and Scott you you
brought these characters to life with
depths and shadings I never even thought
of everybody at DreamWorks for letting
us for taking a chance on a bunch of
first-timers from letting us make the
movie and for marketing it so
brilliantly my agent Andrew kanava my
family especially my mom all the writers
I have ever worked with for everything
that they taught me and finally that
plastic bag in front of the World Trade
Center so many years ago for being
whatever it is that inspires us to do
what we do thank you
[Applause]
he's back Academy Award winner Roberto
Benigni presents the Best Actress Oscar
when the 72nd annual Academy Awards
return here he is
[Applause]
you